hallo mein Name ist Luca und meine
lieben Freunde wir schauen uns heute die
7 gefährlichsten Strände auf der Welt an
fischhöck Südafrika ich komme einer wird
verneint dass die Haie die bekannteste
Gefahr unter dem Wasser darstellen boah
ey geh weg unter den gefährlichsten
Stränden wo sich viele Haie aufhalten
kann man Kapstadt nennen okay in den
Gewässern des Ozeans existiert ein
riesiger menschenfressender Hai er wird
noch der weiße Hai genannt was
das heißt der stimmt da einfach rum und
er lässt sich primär von Menschen Alarm
bei Beginn der heißen Badesaison wird
der Charakter des Angriffs lustigen
Haifisches noch schlimmer die Aggression
wächst und gleichzeitig auch die Angst
der Urlauber also ich weiß nur dass Haie
Urin auf bis zu 1 bis 2 km riechen
können
seitdem pisse ich nicht mehr ins Meer
sondern nur noch in den hotel pool
Südafrikas Regierung hat bereits in den
60er Jahren des letzten Jahrhunderts
unterwassernetze an den meisten Stränden
bei Fische befestigt doch eine 100%ige
Sicherheit haben die Reisenden und die
Einheimischen trotzdem
boah stell mal vor du stehst die denkst
du boah geil hier sind geile Welle und
dann ist Dir das
dieser riesen Schatten guckt dich
plötzlich an alleine 2010 wurden mehr
als 21 Angriffe registriert seid also
vorsichtig und schwimmt nicht zu weit
weg wenn ihr in dieser Region Urlaub
macht
[Musik]
hey ich weiß nicht wie ihr das seht
schreibt so gerne unten in die
Kommentare seid ihr eher Team Hotel Pool
oder Team mehr aber ich bin
hundertprozentig zweiteres
und deswegen ist das halt so blöd in
diesen ganzen Haien und Quallen und
keine Ahnung was Queensland und TV
Islands Australien Australien die
australischen Strände gehören zurecht zu
den gefährlichsten weltweit Grund dafür
ist dass Menschen guck mal wie schön
hier hast du so strahlen dann hier so
ein Fluss stell mal vor hier so eine
fette Villa
Basketballplatz mit kleinen Golfplatz wo
Golfplatz wäre wahrscheinlich schon das
alles hier und dafür ist dass Menschen
oft nicht nur von Heim sondern auch von
Würfelquallen attackiert werden viele
Reisende wissen nichts davon doch diese
Unterwasserwesen haben einen der
gefährlichsten Giftstoffe in der Welt
auch lol ich wusste gar nicht dass sie
so machen
der kommt wirklich was raus aus den
Gefallen ich dachte dass das einfach
wenn das wenn das nur berührt dass das
dann schon schlimm ist ihre Nesselzellen
können eine einfache Verbrennung
hervorrufen aber auch innerhalb von
Minuten für die Traber warum ist DHL
[Musik]
sie sind zwar ganz tot am Boden aber wir
haben hier unten DHL Paket für sie
besonders gefährlich ist die Tatsache
dass diese Tiere fast unbemerkbar im
Wasser sind okay ist also echt gut
aufpassen da würde ich denken dass es
eine ganz normale Alge wäre oh verdammt
jetzt muss ich wieder knossi Denken
im Sommer riskiert er nicht wirklich
doch ab Oktober bis April solltet ihr
das Baden in dieser Gegend lieber
vermeiden dazu dieser Zeit die Quallen
sehr aktiv sind es ist so crazy wie die
dann auch so ihre aktiven Zeiten haben
Bruder die haben ja keinen Kalender oder
eine Uhr das die wissen welcher Tag
gerade ist viel viel Don Beach Thailand
thailändische Inseln locken die
Touristen mit ihren Schönheit und bieten
die Möglichkeit sich vollkommen zu
entspannen und die Zeit zu vergessen
vollkommen entspannen sieht sehr gut das
ist überhaupt nicht überlaufen ist hier
ein beliebter Urlaubsplatz ist der viel
viel dornstrand hier lässt es sich gut
in der Sonne bräunen und im
kristallklaren Wasser baden seid aber
vorsichtig wenn ihr das tut die Gewässer
rundherum will weil wie voll das hier
ist
ich stelle mir das immer vor dass solche
Regionen wo so Berge sind mit so Bäumen
und so kristallklaren Wasser das da auch
keine einzige Zivilisation
Sprachen lernen Babbel es wurden bereits
mehrere Fälle registriert wo die
Schlangen direkt auf den Strand kochen
und die Urlauber panisch davon liefen
wir raten euch deshalb sehr vorsichtig
zu sein Schlangen
ey das dürfen wir nicht Sandra zeigen
die hat so eine Angst vor Schlangen
Zippo light Beach Mexiko wir konnten es
uns nicht einmal im Traum vorstellen
dass auf diesem ruhigen und sehr schönen
mexikanischen Strand mit türkisem Wasser
und weißen Sandstränden so eine Gefahr
lauert die Einheimischen umgehen diese
Gegend insbesondere von April bis Juni
warum zu dieser Zeit entwickelt sich
eine starke unterwasserströmung ach so
ey Bruder ich warte nämlich zwei bin an
der Nordsee mit Ey wenn er von Flut in
die Ebbe rüber geht dann hast du da ganz
andere Strömung als an Mexiko Alter im
Sommer kommen außerdem noch Ebbe und
Flut dazu das Wasser kommt und geht mit
so einer Kraft dass sie sogar einen
Erwachsenen mitschleppen kann nur im
Jahr 2010 wurden 180 Menschen gerettet
die gegen die Strömung keine Chance
hatten 180 Menschen
was unser Planet mit Naturkatastrophen
und generell das ist ja keine
Katastrophe aber so Sachen wie Ebbe und
Flut für eine Macht hat und für eine
Kraft ausüben kann das darf man wirklich
nicht unterschätzen in keiner einzigen
Sekunde table Beach Australien okay
dieser Strand zieht nicht nur Touristen
sondern auch riesige Reptilien an
krokodile sind als Art offiziell vom
Staat geschützt und es ist verboten sie
zu jagen vielleicht führt genau das dazu
dass sie sich unkontrolliert
fortpflanzen und gegenüber dem Menschen
aggressiv wurden oh das ist aber
also wenn ich schwimmen gehe und man
sieht Fische okay man sieht Quallen ok
wenn man selbst ein Hai oder Delfine
sieht würde ich mir noch sagen okay das
macht irgendwie Sinn aber ein Krokodil
verbinde ich nur mit dem Dschungel
irgendwie nicht mit mehr die erhöhte
attackenanzahl führte viele Menschen
dazu sich gegen das Jagdverbot
auszusprechen die Regierung denkt
darüber nach weil sie Angst hat dass
Touristen dann massenweise kommen würden
um die Jagdtrophäen zu holen ja es ist
halt schwierig ne
auf der einen Seite willst du die Tiere
halt leben lassen aber wenn die Tiere
für Menschen so gefährlich sind dann ist
es halt wieder eine andere Sache
den Bereich einfach zu meiden ich glaube
damit würden sich die Anwohner nicht
anfreunden oh das ist nicht ein
Zwickmühle
Hongkong okay übersetzt man die lokale
Bezeichnung sieht aber crazy aus ne
also hier mit diesen riesigen
Hochhäusern denn hier mit einem Strand
und mit dem Wasser das passt irgendwie
gar nicht so richtig zusammen gerade
übersetzt man die lokale Bezeichnung so
heißt der Ort dort wo sich die Möwen
einnisten diese noblen Vögel haben
diesen Strand jedoch schon lange
verlassen weil der Schmutz gerade alle
Grenzen übersteigt ach so
ich dachte das ist der gefährlichste
schon der Welt weil der Möwen hin kacken
Anfang des 20 Jahrhunderts begann hier
eine lokale Bebauung die noch bis heute
fortgeführt wird und die Umwelt zerstört
okay viele Bauabfälle werden direkt ins
Meer geworfen
Wissenschaftler registrieren chemischen
Abfall im Wasser schon seit langem ach
so
jetzt verstehe ich das erstes ist einer
der gefährlichsten Strände weil wenn man
das Schwimmen geht dass man ihn nicht
chemische Krankheit bekommt wegen
irgendwie etwaigen Müll Ressourcen
Atomen Überresten die da rein gelagert
wurden das ist
Krokodil da kommt man zumindest noch
kämpfen Virginia Beach USA man denkt
eigentlich dass die Gefahr nur von den
Meerestieren oder von der Natur ausgehen
kann doch am längsten Strand vom
Atlantik der im Guinness Buch der
Rekorde registriert ist sind auch
Attacken von wildfüchsen keine
Seltenheit stellt euch das mal vor so
ein wildfuchs wenn er ankommen würde ich
würde den streicheln obwohl die Stadt zu
den saubersten und besten unter den
Kurorten dieser Gegend zählt agieren die
nächstgelegenen Parks als Lieferanten
für wilde Tiere und am öftesten kommen
diese aggressiven bilden Füchse vor aber
die trauen sich doch safe nicht seine
Truppe von Menschen anzugreifen oder
ich meine Tier hat ja auch den ganz
klaren Instinkt zu sehen ey die sind
vielleicht eine Stufe zu hoch für mich
es scheint als wäre ihnen langweilig
deshalb attackieren sie von Zeit zu Zeit
die Urlauber und machen somit kein guter
ich dachte das wäre auch ein aber gut
Freunde an der Stelle bin ich dann auch
das heutige Video beenden wenn es euch
gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht was
lernen konntet dann lasst doch gerne
einen Daumen hoch unter dem Video hier
da abonniert meinen Kanal und noch viel
besser klickt auf die Glocke denn dann
bekommt ihr sobald ich neues Video
hochladen eine Benachrichtigung auf euer
Handy und seht direkt aha
da werden wieder Gehirnzellen zerstört